Ian can rake a lawn and bag
the leaves in 5 hours.
Kyandre can rake the same lawn
and bag the leaves in 3 hours.
Working together, how long would
it take them to rake the
lawn and bag the leaves?
So the best way to think about
this is think about how many
bags per hour each
of them can do.
And then we could add the number
of bags per hour they
could produce, and then use that
to figure out how many
hours per bag.
So this first piece of
information, Ian can rake a
lawn and bag the leaves
in 5 hours.
So Ian is 5 hours per bag.
Or you could view this if
we invert it, as 1/5
of a bag per hour.
Or 1 bag every 5 hours.
This and this is saying
the exact same thing.
We can do the same thing
for Kyandre.
In his or her case-- I'm not
sure whether Kyandre is a boy
or girl's name.
He-- well I'll say she.
She'll take 3 hours per bag.
So it's 3 hours per bag.
Or that's another way of saying
she can do, if you
invert this, 1/3 of
a bag per hour.
You could just view it
as 3 hours per 1 bag.
You invert it and you get
1 bag per 3 hours.
1 bag for 3 hours.
This is 5 hours per 1 bag.
Same thing as 1 bag
per 5 hours.
You're just inverting the ratio,
not really changing the
information.
Now, what's their
combined rate?
Well, Ian can do 1/5 of a bag
per hour and Kyandre can do
1/3 of a bag per hour.
So what is this going
to be equal to?
Well, we find a common
denominator here.
Least common multiple
of 5 and 3 is 15.
So let's put it over 15.
So 1/5 is the same thing as
3/15 of a bag per hour.
Want to keep the units
here bag per hour.
And then 1/3 is the same thing
as 5/15 bags per hour.
So when you add them you
get-- 3 plus 5 is 8.
So this is equal to 8/15
bags per hour.
When I say bag, I mean all the
stuff: rake, lawn, and bag.
The whole task's per hour.
8/15 of a task per hour.
So working together, how long
would it take them to rake the
lawn and bag the leaves?
Well, this is how many of the
bagging they can do per hour.
You could invert this.
So if you invert that, you get
this is equal to 15 over 8
hours per bag.
Or if we want to write this as
a mixed number, this is equal
to 1 and 7/8 hours per bag.
Let me write it like this.
1 and 7/8 hours per bag.
And if we really want to get a
sense of what 7/8 is in terms
of hours, we can multiply
it by minutes.
So 7/8 hours times 60
minutes per hour.
Let's see what we can do here.
60 and 8 are both
divisible by 4.
8 divided by 4 is 2.
60 divided by 4 is 15.
7 times 15 is-- 7
times 10 is 70.
Plus 35 is 105.
So this is equal to
105/2 minutes.
Which is equal to what?
52.5 minutes.
So as a combined effort, it will
take them 1 hour and 52.5
minutes to do it together.
And we're done.